Christopher Riley, Screenwriter,
Author, and Instructor: You find
all of these but they're like you
know their cards in your poker hand
and you're not sure where you're going to play
them or even if you're going to play them.
Film Courage: When we're developing a character,
how much are we charting out all of sort of the
wonderful and terrible things that have happened
to them? Are we doing this beforehand before
we get into the actual story, we're kind of
coming up with a checklist of defining moments?
Christopher: This is one of the confounding
qualities of storytelling. We don't have
a linear process where we do this
first and the second. We sort of try
we have to have we have to approach the story
somehow but I think that what we do is we
I typically have a notion for what
is the story what maybe in a sentence
what is the story I want to tell and that
tells me something about a character and
and also something about the plot
that is it's somebody like this
trying to you know climb out of a well and so but
then I go back to the character and I said well
I have more questions for you character where did
you come from how did you get in that well what
were you doing in the field in the first place and
sometimes the answers are really surprising to me
sometimes they come as sort of epiphanies as I'm
out for a run or taking a shower or lying in bed
often though they come as a result of
just the ditch digging of sitting and
asking these questions I know that this
person to be interesting needs to have
both strength and weakness when did
they discover they had that strength
when did they first experience the
crippling quality of that weakness and um
then I come bring the character back to the story
and now they're doing more interesting things
that I didn't expect them to do because there's
more to that character and so I discover more
twists and turns that are potential within
say the events or the plot of the story
and then I go back to the character so I'm I
think I'm it's a very messy recursive process
when I am finding these defining moments
for a character I don't know if any of them
will end up on screen at first I'm
just discovering what are these moments
and then so there are things I can do with
a defining moment I can just know about it
and it's going to inform how I write dialogue
for this character other times I'm going to say
if I were writing Pixar's Finding Nemo I would
say oh that moment when marlin's whole family
gets eaten by a barracuda I think we should see
that that's really visual and exciting and tragic
would Pixar allow us to start a children's movie
with that kind of scene because if we were to do
that then we would really understand why Marlon is
this overprotective father who won't let Nemo have
any adventure have any fun experience any danger
and we won't view him just as you know oh that
neurotic marlin we will feel with him well of
course he is a hyper vigilant parent because
this tragedy struck him and we
witnessed it we experienced it with him
now when I first came up with that I didn't
somebody did if I was the one who had come up
with that I i wouldn't have known at first
does that make it into the movie or not
there are other moments that we don't see but a
character talks about they just tell you the story
of what happened or they allude to the
story whatever makes great dialogue and then
other times there are moments right in the middle
of the movie where a character transforms and
here I think the great example is Michael Corleone
and the godfather so we know that Michael is a
war hero just back from world war ii he's the
son who was not supposed to get mixed up with
the family's crime business he was supposed to go
on and maybe be a senator maybe even a president
but after his father gets gunned down Michael
decides he's got to take matters into his own
hands and so he goes to meet the crime boss who
had his father gunned down and the police captain
who protects that other crime boss because to meet
them at an Italian restaurant he has a gun planted
in the bathroom and he excuses himself from the
table goes back to the bathroom gets the gun
and then there's this long pause as Michael
smoothes his hair and sort of allows himself to
make his choice am I going to step across this
threshold from which there can be no return or not
and then the director has set it up so Michael
has to pass through three sets of doors
as he returns into the
restaurant from the bathroom
just to emphasize visually this is a threshold
there is a real boundary of before and after here
Michael walks out into the restaurant guns down
the police captain and the other crime boss and
the rest of the movie and the next movie and
the next movie the die is cast for all of those
in that moment of the change of Michael's
legal status from war hero to killer
there's also a moral and a spiritual
change that happens in him and
he thinks he's done this for
all the best reasons for family
but in the end he becomes someone who kills
members of his family for the family and he is
undone by this action by this choice that he's
made in a moment that defines him so you find
that moment and you think ah that's probably
a scene in the movie and in fact that becomes
the fulcr of the whole movie the moment that
defines Michael as who will become the godfather
so you you find all of these but they're like you
know their cards in your poker hand and you're not
sure where you're going to play them or even if
you're going to play them and that is the messy
organic artistic process I suppose of crafting
a story but you can't craft it if you don't have
the raw materials from which to craft it and
I think that defining moments are one of those
really rich materials that we have to work with
when we're telling stories about characters.